craziest thing a guy ever asked me to do
was to tap-dance on his balls with
stilettos may be anyways gave me $100 uh
smell my feet my feet something like for
God's telling the lip they put their toe
away from my armpits - look at that rub
his nose and pinch his nipples shove a
vacuum cleaner handle up there but asked
me to hold a gun up to his head and
saying Mary Mary Mary this is all by
Mary yes so - yes well I am sucking on
his car Oh a guy wanted me to use a
vibrator on him and done the lick is the
nipples at the same time what's the
craziest thing a guy on street
harassment well a golden shower pan
pee in their mouth what is he singing a
guy ever did is his wanted me to piss in
his mouth and swallow his piss no please
my mouth and swallow his piss strap on a
dildo and [__] it
um [__] with a condom in his butt the
guy wanted to come to my mouth then me
spit his comeback in his mouth so he
could swallow it
this deed wanted me to watch him suck
his own dick
the dogs deep I don't even know who doc
no please let me tell you the story the
man was [__] I'm talking to him
really having sex with an animal and he
wanted me to pee on him right he's
[__] it you want me to piss on him
wife's [__] it was this little you
just kept doing I can see all are gonna
kill the dog you want to walk around the
block
Blake Nicky and I did thing but he was
there at nighttime
like around 4:30 time like by 2:30 to
something like did in the morning the
craziest thing in guys asked me to do
was probably I had to tie him up for his
arms his legs and tie his balls up and
we had a dodo about let me see I've got
like this big in like this long and he
wanted me to show his ass but it
wouldn't like so easy like it wasn't
like it was like ooh yeah what's the
craziest request any of your male
customers ever made one guy asked me to
actually defecate money not that was the
craziest thing
um [__] in the bowls leaking you like
ice cream somebody asked me to [__] on
them literally will you pick this [__]
in my mouth
what I haven't had asked me to [__] in
his mouth I have that feeling has me to
[__] in her mouth pooping in somebody's
mouth [__] on and then he was rubbing my
[__] on his chest while he was jacking
off with the other hand and he was
calling it peanut butter peanut butter
yes
general what is the craziest thing any
of your male customers has ever asked
you to do to castrate him really yes Wow
take a knife
you tie his balls and shoelaces
until they turn purple okay
he wants me to basically cut him you
know I did it just enough until it drew
blood and then I had to go that was
nasty
that was like true it just ripped out
that that's crazy